now back in Sutherland Springs we're
hearing about the many acts of heroism
at the First Baptist Church from those
who survived and from those who of
course succumbed by now you've heard
about Steven Williford the plumber who
stopped the shooting by engaging with
the killer with a gun of his own and
tonight we're learning more about
another person
Joanne ward this mother of four died in
a heroic attempt to shield her own
children from the killer joining us now
from Sutherland Springs is a dear friend
of this heroic woman and she's the
family spokesperson at a very difficult
time Vonda Smith and also Texas's
lieutenant governor Dan Patrick who
spoke at length with the hero mr.
Wilford tonight both of you it is good
to see you both
under such difficult circumstances Vonda
I want to start with you I had a chance
to talk to you briefly you just happen
to be listening to my radio show this
morning and you called in yeah because
you had just spent time with Joanne
Ward's daughter nine years old right who
had been in that church tell us what she
told you the first thing she told me was
that the reason that she didn't get shot
like everybody else was because her
momma threw her on the ground
I told her to hide and she did and she
said I didn't get shot because I was
hiding and she proceeded that minor
injury correct and and and yet she never
said she had none two of her siblings no
died correct she she wasn't injured she
could have been she says that a bullet
went right by her face and knocked off
her glasses and she was not even skates
so as soon as Joanne threw her on the
ground
she stayed hiding
and I'm sorry what was your next
question and two of her siblings died in
this horrific - her siblings died yeah
Joanne as soon as she threw her on the
ground she scooped up her other three
that were sitting next to her in a Pew
Ryland who's five and Brooke who is five
and Emily who's seven and she
immediately covered them with her body
and that's that's exactly how Rihanna
Rihanna you know described it she just
said she was on top of them and they
just I guess it all happened so fast I
assume but others she was this is the
mother's ultimate sacrifice Dan as
lieutenant governor of Texas you
presided over natural disaster in the
last few months and now spending time
tonight was Stephen Willeford the hero
in all of this mother Nell Joanne Ward
who is deceased was killed Stephen
survived this but he engaged the killer
tell us what he told you tonight I had
an extraordinary hour with him and a
pastor earlier this evening and and I
asked Stephen permission of what to say
on his behalf and he said tell our and
tell the country tell the world I'm not
a hero I'm a victim he said I lost my
friends I lost people in my community he
doesn't want to be treated like a hero
Laura he just reacted he said God gave
him great presence of mind and and and
calmness as he as he walked out that
door facing the shooter he said he'd
like to go to the hospital as I as I did
later tonight I went to the hospital to
visit some of those who are wounded and
have lost others and he said I'd like to
go to the hospital with you but I just
can't right now
he's a he's a Christian most of all he
said dan tell everyone I'm a Christian
and I'm part of this faith community
that is going to stand strong he's a
humble man he's a hero to all of us but
to himself he's another victim and
that's how he wants to be seen dan is
there any doubt in your mind after
spending time with him tonight as
distraught as he is and I want to hear
from both of you on this that were he
not the type of man he is I know he's
humble he doesn't want any credit but
President Trump was right we would have
had a lot more carnage this man was
hell-bent on shooting up whatever he
could find it looked like I said to him
Laura I said Stephen I know you don't
want to be hero but understand that your
reaction probably saved many other lives
there would have been a police shootout
for example that that police officers
could have been wounded or killed they
drove by another church in the chase the
gunman could have stopped at that church
because obviously this was more than
just domestic violence for me Laura this
was just another attack on people of
faith in this world whether you're Jews
or Muslims or Christians today people of
faith are under attack and so there's no
question in my mind that's that Stephen
saved the lives of countless others and
is still wrestling with this he's not
getting a lot of sleep and he's still
working through this but there'll be a
there'll be a time that he'll tell his
story in detail but now he just wants to
be known as a Christian and a victim Wow
and to think Vonda about how much our
society focuses on celebrity and what
you have and what you're wearing and and
where you went to school all of that and
at a time like this you see a mother's
love for her children I have three
children
and I I got it all down on my knees
tonight and I prayed with my children
for the people of Texas again crup I
mean and my kids don't really understand
it they're little but I was crying
myself thinking of her ultimate
sacrifice
are you surprised knowing Joan as you do
that she did this instinctively for her
children Joann always had her children
at the top of her mind
her ideas her thoughts everything when
we would go to lunch
even with Joann sitting there with her
children we couldn't carry on a normal
conversation with her because she would
be interrupted by her children not
because they were misbehaved they were
perfectly behaved but if they needed
anything
it was the drop of a hat it was about
her children and that's Joanne's heart
it was always giving her children first
place and her family and for her to do
this she always told me even and it's
just it's the thing that you hear
sometimes parents say but you never
think they'll have to she said I would
die for my children and she ended up
having to do that and very end and that
does not surprise any of us in this
community that knows her because she
loved them so and she she gave it up for
them ultimately Laura dan dan you can go
ahead yeah good I just hear should be
arriving to the hospital tonight the
this this this faith that we're seeing
this faith-based community is
unbelievable and I went to visit him a
lady the names have not been released so
I won't release her name but she had
been shot multiple times her daughter
her granddaughter was the floor above
her in critical condition her husband
was killed this is just unimaginable I
went and visited another lady who today
was just for the first time I was maybe
the first person she had talked to and
she said tell me did they all die
I wasn't ready and but the lady I
visited previously had said to me I lost
80% of my friends I lost my husband my
granddaughter's in critical condition
but a church family went to heaven an
entire church family went to heaven
together and we will be together with
them again and that's what I shared with
the other lady when she said did they
all die and I said no but a church
family went together to heaven to be
with the Lord I Laura you and I have
known each other a long time as fellow
Christians I've never seen a statement
of faith like we have seen a pastor said
earlier to me just a few minutes ago Dan
a lone star welcomed Jesus Christ into
this world and a Lone Star State is
showing that faith is stronger than evil
and hate and Joanne Joanne I want to say
you reached out to Joanne Ward a few
years ago she was having a really tough
time you helped bring her to
Christianity she it on eclis she goes to
in connects with this church and she
ends up dying there now a lot of the
atheists and a lot of the cynics will
say see that the faith killed her she
she got close to God and look at what
happened to her there is no God how
would you respond to that mm-hmm
I I don't even know what to say to that
I just know that this woman's faith was
so strong I I may not have brought her
to Christianity I know that her faith
was wavering and her faith strengthened
over the three years I've known her and
she did end up in church and that is
where she died and the thing that that I
know that Joanne would want people to
know is that live for Christ no matter
what she was dragging people to church
she was begging her best friend Cody to
go to Sunday school with her she that
was her heart and no it evil is here and
that is not God's plan God's plan is not
for evil it's for good and if we would
turn to him
he's got an ultimate good for us in
store and it may not be here on this
earth but it'll end up that way and
that's the end of the story because we
know the end of the book lieutenant
governor Patrick in Vonda thank you for
sharing this incredibly difficult moment
with us but I think we need to confront
evil and we need to call it out
we need to stand for what is right and
you helped do us do that for us tonight
thank you both thank you and